should I leave my jacket on for visual
effect or take it off because it's hot
take it off because it's hot all right
I'm gonna take off my jumping and I love
the caffeine keep it up or feel free to
hiss moan boots
I don't know whatever
hi everyone it's Drew and it is time for
the Drew's News podcast where we're
serving up a little pop culture some
happy news a dash of inspiration and
just an all-around good time today we're
covering everything from Olivia Wilde's
bikini clad return to Instagram lying
about having kids to get out of work and
we're doing it with two very special
guests I'm starting to like drool I'm so
excited I don't know why like I'm losing
control
um Leah and Joanna who the world knows
as the co-founders and hosts of The Home
edit you guys I'm so happy you're here
I have to brag I'm friends with you guys
I've been on your Netflix show you guys
have done our show multiple times
um I am a sister branding wise we're
both in Walmart we have the same
Fearless leaders who manage Our Brands
and who believe that we all belong
together and that there's so much
Symmetry and I'm just happy to say like
I feel like you know you know just an
aspiring girlfriend we're life Partners
yeah no I would think so I hope so I
remember when we did our first segment I
was like oh my God I think we might be
all the same person I think so too and
we were like are we best friends now
yeah yeah
exactly it happened fast for us it's
like the movie Step Brothers he's like
did we just become best friends
yup yes that's exactly what it's like
and I just also on another note like I
just admire everything you put out into
the world because I think you have truly
changed the perspective think what you
put into the world is not only helpful
but just extraordinarily powerful well
we appreciate that and we that is the
intention the intention is when you live
a clutter-free life when you have a life
filled with organization you it is a
form of self-care it is Wellness it is
the a little bit of Zen and you know we
often talk about controlling the
controllables because so much of life is
chaotic and if you can just add a little
bit of order to your life it's amazing
how much it how long it goes and how
much it benefits you an organization is
an opportunity people see it as a chore
but I think it's about reframing your
thinking and realizing this is an
opportunity and being excited about it
be better than love making it
I don't know I cleaned out my closet
this morning and I was like yep Better
Than Sex
what do you guys like want to share with
people like I didn't even realize I
forgot I had done that this morning and
then I'm like going into my confessional
Booth with you guys and like being
excited to share my information about
organizing because you're you know the
goddesses of that entity what do you
want like is there like an ice cream
fetish you have so if you met like the
dryers man I will start I have Bagels in
my purse because whenever we're in
Manhattan I have to eat as many bagels
as I possibly can I cannot miss an
opportunity it has purse Bagels I
sometimes love you even more have you
been to like Essa Bagel number one
I'm doing a bagel taste test and um on
the podcast and Essa Bagel is number one
every morning ask Lauren lined up
outside like it's a nightclub I know
because it's a postmate situation it is
and I get three because I have to have
options
she gets a regular one one with vegan
cream cheese and the one with just
butter right and I have different
purposes for different ones okay so the
plain one I don't want to put the
Everything one in my purse because
that's rude right yeah and it's smelling
all day yeah so the plane goes with me
through the day oh my God I I'm I'm even
more with you that I was before this is
a real thing and I just want to say when
we're eating breakfast at our hotel
which does not allow outside food okay
all of a sudden Joanna will take out a
bagel from her purse and start spreading
butter on it and then a man a postmate
man walks in with a paper bag looking
around and Joanna calls him over to the
table and then as he's dropping the bag
another man arrives with another
post-mated Bagel sometimes from
different locations sometimes it's from
different locations it is yeah and that
is okay because that is living your
bliss it is we're only here for a finite
time right like don't miss that girl
totally be that girl what about you Clea
well I'm a champagne kind of person so I
my type Mrs tadinger walked in you would
fall all over yourself my husband and I
in March um the day after I was
diagnosed with cancer we had a trip
planned to Paris and everyone my mother
was like there's no you are not going
you just got diagnosed I was like well
there's nothing they're gonna do
tomorrow so yes I'm still going on my
trip trip and we went to the Champaign
region of France and I practically like
laid down in the middle of the street
and just soaked it in I was like because
they told me that there's actually the
street that uh you know Moe Shandong of
Cleco and everything is on is the most
expensive Street in the world because
all the sellers are filled with
champagne bottles so like in the middle
of street when you're standing there
you're like I am a top like hundreds of
thousands of just bottles of champagne
so I just let that I've also gotten a
letter from the oh wait this is a real
thing hold on this is this is breaking
news this is breaking Drew's news I've
never said this before I'm probably
gonna get like a put on citation okay so
we I used to have a saying that said
champagne's basically sparkling water
like it's hydrating you put ice in it
it's fine like it's like you know it's
not like you would just say it like
champagne champagne is basically
sparkling water I got a cease and desist
from the Champaign region of France
letterhead
saying that I was degrading the
centuries-old tradition of champagne and
you're like and if you only knew I'm one
of your number one consumers
add some ice and it's basically I mean
like it's basically I've heard in in
French if you add some ice to Wine it
could be called the piscine it is which
means a swimming pool right so it's okay
for that but not the champagne I don't
understand by the way full circle and
I'm so happy to say this your last round
of chemo when you posted the picture you
had champagne glasses in the picture
always and I can't think of a more
amazing reason to celebrate your journey
how you shared it with everyone how
gracious you were to bring everyone on
it like if someone wants to be your
girlfriend like me I felt invited on the
journey and I also felt like it was just
a love letter to bravery and opening
yourself up and not suffering in silence
allowing people in and it also felt like
heart-wrenching educational I felt like
I I got to invest in the in the length
and the
moments with you I mean what made you
decide to share it the way you did
because it was such an extraordinary
invitation one that affected me more
than a lot in this lifetime I've had I
actually I felt that deeply from you you
were so supportive the minute I
announced my diagnosis and continued to
be I never felt like it was even a
question whether or not I was going to
share it I think that it is a privilege
and an opportunity to educate people
that young people
pre-even the age where you should be
getting mammograms can absolutely get
breast cancer and I think sharing my
journey inspiring people to get screened
take their health seriously prioritize
it over incredibly busy schedules I mean
I I did not have time to get breast
cancer no one has time to deal with
finding something that might be a
humongous problem and require a year of
treatment but if you don't prioritize it
I've said this to many people many times
not knowing you have breast cancer is
different than not having breast cancer
you need to take your health seriously
and I knew that if I could inspire
people to take it seriously and and say
look I have absolutely no family history
I have done every piece of genetic
testing I have none of it I was under
the age of 40 when my tumors both of
them I had two
um I was almost stage three my tumors
started to arrive when they were forming
I was under the age of 40. there is
absolutely not a reason in this world
why I could think of to not share that
information and I have been lucky enough
to work very closely with Vanderbilt
which is the amazing institution that
has given me care this whole year and
the Cancer Institute at Vanderbilt is
world class it's one of the best ever
and one thing that has been really
important that they've asked me to be on
their board is because people think
about older people getting cancer and of
course people understand we work very
closely with Saint Jude and children's
Cancers and things like that but one
thing that has gone missing from
people's minds is how many even children
could be orphaned by their parents
getting cancer because of how young
people are now who are getting cancer
and not even realizing it they're not
getting screened they're not getting
tested they're not taking it seriously
so it's it's important and I it to me
it's been the privilege of my life to
share this information that's probably
the most important thing I'll ever do
and the impact that's what I meant about
the educational piece and you have
empowered you have included your tone of
which you've done the entire journey and
the way you speak of it now is so
inviting you know it's not it doesn't
feel taboo I think a lot of people want
to avoid it which is part of why they
don't know that they you know something
might be wrong
um we use a myriad of behaviors you know
to sort of not deal and when health
comes in it becomes the number one
priority whether you like it or not and
it trumps all else and I just I I feel
closer to you through this and thank you
for letting us like support and cheer
you on and be an advocate and I I'm your
journey forever changed me and
everything you just said I was hanging
on your every word you are so strong so
awesome I did such an honor to like be a
budding friend to you both of you I'm in
love with you both we're in love with
you yes and and you know we're I'm happy
to be on this journey with both of you
uh forever you don't have a choice I
need you on my journey I know you two
are the dynamic duo
you are the best couple and I'm just
trying to get in a throttle
we have to go to a quick commercial and
we'll be right back
[Music]
shall we dive into some nice stories
Story number one which is just fun
Breakfast Club reunion Molly Ringwald
and Ali shitty just posted on IG after
hanging out nearly 38 years after the
films February 1985 debut the former
brat Packers caught up for a reunion
that Ringwald is calling an early
Christmas present
oh my God this picture I know I know
it's incredible everything well you know
so Joanna and I have a podcast called
best friend energy and nothing is
bringing more best friend energy than
this picture I know do they want to come
on our podcast look at them they are so
happily in love with each other I love
that they love each other I know and
after I mean filming a movie that long
ago and such a sensational like I don't
know iconic yeah moment in everyone's
life I think having such a wonderful
friendship I wonder what their
relationship has been like up until now
do you think that they're not as close
because it's been so long so this is
like a real reunion I mean I know that
Molly Ringwald didn't she go to live in
France for a while yes that's correct
um maybe visited the champagne yeah
um and Ali sheedy's just you know been
like doing cool Indie movies and but you
can tell yeah the love I think as
someone who had to like you know have
chemistry with a romance and and and
certain men most of which came very easy
I got really lucky at most of the guys I
was lucky enough to work with were good
people and it was just easy to have that
chemistry with them I always was like I
would never know how to fake chemistry
with a woman totally like my female
friendships are so strong and it is like
that you can't fake and I think looking
at their picture like that is it's a
double arm yeah
genuine smiles and snuggles and goodness
and joy and women can't fake it with
each other no yeah it would definitely
be if they did not love each other it's
a one-armed situation there's some space
between them maybe Temple to Temple but
they're not cheek to cheek I think I
think this this whole thing tells the
difference that's right I agree and the
facial expressions and the smiles are so
real I don't know what I would do
without my girlfriends you know I would
be so lost I didn't really have family
growing up so they were my first family
now I have these two daughters and you
know when I'm planning trips first and
foremost I try to plan the girls trips
like you know my girls trips uh and get
those locked and loaded you know for the
year and then I go hard into the
girlfriend trips like the adult women
like okay now that we I've booked
everything for life I know the work I
know the schedule what are we doing and
nothing is dear to me than my time with
my friends it could be a sleepover a
casual dinner a hang on the couch taking
a trip it could be you know a micro
macro mellow epic anything in between
girlfriends are or everything everything
Joanna and I have been looking forward
to this week all year yeah because this
was going to mean the end of treatment
we were going to be in New York City
during the holidays we could not crack
your fast enough and Joanna was gonna
stuff her purse with Bagels Bagels oh
she has them here if anyone would like a
puppy no just a plane
she doesn't want her Bagels to be
offensive it's not she's not trying to
make it like egg salad no that's right
it's not Tuna on a subway yeah
um I did bring a tuna sandwich on an
airplane recently so did my mother and I
was like you cannot do that I know I
felt so embarrassed but I was starving
all right okay the next story comes from
the Wall Street Journal and it is a
holiday debate speaking of the holidays
is it ever okay to gift clothing one
fashionista says yes sartorial presents
are handy and they encourage the gifty
to push their style boundaries
um well another says no garment gifting
um it's impossible to get right and a
tense unwrapping episode is inevitable
what do you guys think to close or not
we actually had this debate on the drive
here yeah we did you're talking about
this very question okay so Joanna give
give your hot take okay first of all we
have to separate categories so first of
all you're wearing the sexiest sweater
it's like sweet and sexy all at the same
time thank you I'll take the compliment
yeah that's really good
um I would say a comfy PJs yes because
those are like Get Cozy live your best
life that is a gift it is loungewear
yeah think like that that is a gift
giving opportunity clothing I no no it's
you're it's a tripwire like you're gonna
offend someone in somewhere you're
they're gonna be it's gonna be too big
too small it just seems like a landmine
no thank you like if it if the clothing
comes in just like small medium large
like a lounge set yeah go for it yes if
don't buy Me jeans no you know what I
mean like what size are you getting and
then you feel bad oh you think a blouse
yeah like no yeah like do I dress poorly
no I have a lot of feelings about it
even outerwear which we actually paused
on outerwear is like maybe but then it's
like no because things can be boxy the
Cut's wrong like you could it could be
too long it's not a right fit it's stick
to something that's just like comfy cozy
casual it's a real gift and not like
doesn't feel like an attack or a
judgment okay that I just maybe I'm
projecting no this is totally clear it
does like loungewear like if anyone
gives me socks I'm so thrilled enthusia
totally and you're right also like I was
lucky enough
um the whole Drew's news crew gave me um
my favorite free City sweats with Drew's
face on it perfect exactly number one
gift like I've ever gotten Ross Matthews
made that macaroni and cheese
yeah but I would love to live in a vat
of macaroni and cheese
um but you're right I don't often ever
buy anyone clothes nor get clothes
because as you said so eloquently it's a
tripwire yeah it is and who needs that
on both ends you don't need it it's a
very personal choice how you wear things
what you wear do you like a certain
drape a certain size a certain fit or
you want this tight and this loose yeah
it's weird and also when someone is
considering your size in a way that I'm
like I'm like I don't want you're like
thinking about it
like intimately it's gonna fit into
these jeans but it's like all a wet pant
great yeah yeah totally all right I'm
glad that we are all in agreement here
well I went in uh completely neutral and
I'm coming out real strong with you guys
you know what you do it's now I think
it's weird and now anyone who gives me a
piece of clothing you're gonna be like
you were thinking about me like that no
her next story I'm so curious is to
thoughts um that you guys have about
this this tweet just sparked a major
debate online it reads at my next job
I'm gonna lie about having a kid so I
can leave the office anytime I want like
everyone else with children clearly she
doesn't have clearly she doesn't have
kids and
um yeah because I I don't think anybody
is making that argument nobody so we
also shockingly have very strong
feelings about this okay can I bring it
yeah okay so as as a mother we are all
mothers right if you get a call that
says your child has thrown up every
single muscle in your body deflates is
it is the worst feeling in the world and
what what people don't understand who
don't have kids the hardest job is
actually being a mother to your children
so if you have have to leave work to go
home and take care of a sick child I
can't think of a job that is harder than
that no correct I'd rather be at work
I'm not I'm not trying to leave and be
like my kids are saying nothing is
harder than being at home and I like
hats off to all the stay-at-home parents
it is I can't imagine a harder job so
leaving your actual job to go home
parents don't make up that their kids
are sick we would never do we also yell
Jumanji we don't we don't put that out
in the world you know what I mean like
if you want to leave work early like
come up with a respectable experience
like something yeah
also I just I'm not a good liar and it's
I'm not good at the lie I you can tell
I'm lying in the middle of it because
I'm like even though I've acted in my
life I have no skills to to pull off a
lie in real life
um I look guilty as I'm saying it like
you're not believable that I'm lying and
then also like I just don't want to get
caught I don't want to lie I just I it's
not worth it no it's not worth it
um I don't even want to we laugh about
this but I don't even want to bring a
peanut on the plane when we're going
entering it like in and out I'll bring a
tuna sandwich she thinks that like the
agricultural police are going to get
better
actually if we've gone to Canada this is
a true story Joanna like like throws her
arms up in the air like she is
submitting to the police like the the
generality she's like I have a piece
she's like I have an energy bar and
they're like man like that's fine and
she's like but you should check me yeah
just make sure so I see you and feel you
so much on this and also she every
single time we've ever checked in at the
airport when they're like do you have
like a nine volt battery or whatever the
thing is that she always says I have a
rechargeable toothbrush and they're like
and 100 of the time they've told her
that that is not what the battery issue
is right but every time she has to tell
them just in case the laws have changed
listen I I cannot tell a lie I know
that's Richard Nixon who was telling a
lie but we really can but I yeah no I'm
not good at it and you're right the
karma doesn't work if you're gonna if
you're going to lie don't use a kid yeah
that's right a mom never ever would so I
just want to say for everyone listening
if someone says I am really sorry my
child is sick I have to go home trust me
they are dreading it more than anyone
else what kind of nothing could be worse
wild such good perspective and feedback
on that tweet okay moving on
um so sadly I guess Olivia Wilde and
Harry Styles have recently uh parted
ways Olivia has returned to social media
for the first time since
um and boy did she return in a bikini
cracking up with her girlfriend Babs
Birchfield I mean
thoughts okay let me tell you I can
one-up this photo Joanna and I were just
at the baby to baby Gala which you know
very well you've been honored and she
was there in the tiny little top yeah I
think she was in this bikini top At The
Gala she was in a long skirt and this
bandeau bikini top or like a version of
it yes and again it was like right on
the heels of like maybe the breakup and
all this and I was like is this like a
Revenge body moment is this like I'm
gonna get photographed like all of my ab
muscles like I don't I don't know but I
was I was like a lookie Lou I have to
admit abs for days like so again I think
she's just like you know what I am not
sad about my hairy breakup and I'm going
to show everyone that I have the body to
end all bodies she is like so stunning
so beautiful she she knows this friend
of mine or they're they're close and my
friend was going to her place and I was
like can I like send a message
through you to her
um I think she is is so extraordinary
and I think that she should just take
all the you know Fascination as such a
compliment I mean when everybody can't
stop talking about you it means that
you're just on the top of mind I think
that's right she is an impactful strong
gorgeous woman director you know it just
she's she's just so beautiful and she's
come off a few months of people just
talking all the time that's what like I
wanted to send a message of like I
literally like if you are the person
that every person chooses to focus on
that is a giant compliment I agree like
it should be taken as nothing else and
because you are the fascination of
everyone I mean that must not be easy to
live with
um but what a compliment and I think she
will continue to be the fascination of
everyone for many years to come yes I
think I mean I was impressed that she
showed up looking with such posture and
poison she was one of the presenters
yeah and it was it was the posture and
Poise how was the whole event I've been
an angel to baby to baby for years I
love that event do you know that night I
believe the amount and this is an
organization baby to baby one of the
most powerful organizations on behalf of
kids and their parents and mothers and
family is the most effective
organization and I believe that that
night they've now raised over 12 million
dollars we did over 12 million dollars
that night it was amazing
um you've been an honoree before and I
haven't even been in honorary yes I was
positive many years ago and I'm I'm an
angel as well I have always joked that
I'm the only non-famous angel like like
the list reads it's actually pretty
amazing like of course like Drew
Barrymore's in the bees I'm under Molly
Sims because my last name's Shearer and
I remember the first time Molly realized
I was an angel she saw the lesson she
goes my Clash here and I was like yes
Molly yeah because she produces home
edit with you on Netflix and so I just
happened to come after her in the
alphabet but that's the only thing that
we like I like Molly is like Towers
above me and her like stunning Gala
gowns and looks like an angel floating
down the carpet and then there's the
model and a gorgeous woman yeah I'm the
only non-famous angel but that's okay
but you know I actually think it's it's
funny I'm just in the best company ever
I just happen to be an angel for the
last like decade so I've just been I was
an early adopter I'm so glad because
they are the most effective organization
yes I've ever seen in my life the way
that Kelly and Nora have moved the
needle on how to get effective change
through yes is unbelievable please check
out the organization baby to baby and
you will see why every woman is out
there on behalf of this organization
it's for such a good cause all right um
we have to go to a quick commercial and
we'll be right back
[Music]
and we're back okay now for our last
story and this one is a bit
controversial
um okay this is really interesting
so this tick tocker Tanner leather Stein
is that really his name I know that's my
first thought I know well because it's
it's uh it's all about leather he's
going viral for literally cutting up
designer purses apart to show whether or
not they're worth the price tag and in
one of his viral videos Tanner cuts a
twelve hundred dollar designer wallet
with a pair of scissors and concluded
that the wallet is made up of thirty
dollars worth of leather bringing the
estimated cost in the manufacture of
ninety dollars and Tanner said it's
twelve hundred dollars for the price tag
and you're paying a lot for the status
that comes with the logo okay I want to
know thoughts because living in
Manhattan on every corner is you know a
table with knockoffs and they are so
good you would never ever know except I
would okay so let me just say I have I
have the scissors I have such strong
opinions about all this but I just want
want to say my history I went to Parsons
School of Design in New York my first
job was working at Hermes of Paris so I
worked for a leather goods company is
there anyone better to talk to this
about no because I also worked
everywhere I have worked everywhere but
Hermes is the I worked for the ultimate
leather goods company in the world I
would argue and I believe in their
products so much not necessarily their
price point is a choice for everyone to
make right it is very expensive but I
can tell you the Craftsman the
craftsmanship uh to make a certain type
of their bag one of their most famous
bags of Birkin is nine months of
craftsmanship and one person makes that
the whole way through this is not
something that's on an assembly line
it's like an Atelier yes like you have
to train forever to become this person
and the the Leathers the the Skins
whether it's exotic whether it's lamb
whether it's pebbled all of this is so
it's everything to them it's just it's
through it's what they're born and
raised and bred with it's awesome
fallible yes it is so there are certain
leather companies that I will get by a
hundred percent and I will tell you that
again you can feel the weight of the
bags you can see the stitching you can
see how it all comes together first of
all the thought of anyone taking a pair
of scissors to a bag like that makes me
cringe in ways that I find physically
uncomfortable when wearing a turtleneck
and I'm getting kind of hives thinking
about it I'm like I hope no one's
touching that but then there are other
companies that play around a little bit
I think with the quality and that is is
it all of our faults because it's kind
of the same thing as real estate right
something's only worth what someone's
willing to pay and if someone's willing
to pay twelve hundred dollars for a
wallet that has a logo on it then what
is the company the logo is going to be
worth whatever the difference is it just
is and that is not the company's fault I
don't think okay the fact that you just
took it to the place of real estate I
think it's true was incredibly
interesting because it's true when you
arbitrary a place a neighborhood boom I
mean whoa I did not expect that analogy
to come into it well and you know again
it's like okay if we're talking about
just the bare bones cost of the silk in
a shirt the yarn and the hardware right
if you're thinking about just hard costs
sure we can have a conversation about
hard costs but that's not the world we
live in the world we live in is about
perception it's a it's about you know a
perceived reality of each other's
sentence everyone's favorite couple
at least something for
why would a company be like you know
what actually it only cost me 30 bucks
right so here's you're just charging for
the logo I mean they can charge
technically they should be able to
charge what they want and there there
are companies who again will say It's
Made In Paris but really you know a
certain percentage of it was made in
China made in the U.S and it's assembled
in Paris so that they can stamp that on
there there's a lot that goes into
luxury goods but again it's only worth
what someone's willing to pay if
everyone decided tomorrow that a 1200
Chanel wallet was not worth it and zero
people were buying it I guarantee you
Chanel would drop the prices they're not
going to just sit on inventory but if
all these people are queuing up to buy a
1200 wallet I mean that's just the way
it goes interesting God I really came to
the right person I just I mean you know
and again sometimes I think it's worth
it sometimes I don't think the quality's
there but at the end of the day it's
conspiracy well as long as they're not
lying and saying that it's something
that it's not right they're not saying
it's stuffed with gold right you know I
like that if you have the means and it's
what you want to do everybody has their
fetishes and their things and their
likes and dislikes I love if you can't
but you want it I love the knockoffs I
do and I know I'm going to Fashion help
for saying it no go ahead I'm like I
love that there's an option you know
good on you I think it's great also also
I love the second hand Market you know
if you wanna if you want to buy a Chanel
wallet I love going go to a consignment
place yeah yes you know absolutely
someone wears it twice you're so
interesting about that is you if you go
outside of any major city and you Thrift
you can find the best deals and if you
go on most websites you can find some
really interesting things and there's a
whole range out there no judgments love
it something for everyone the gamut I
love it no I think it's boy your
expertise in this area was really
fortunate it happened to be something
else well it's funny because I found
this story and I brought it to the news
and then we everyone was like no I think
we should talk to cleann Joanna about it
and hearing you I'm like oh my God or
just clear she has a she has the right
opinion about this she has the expertise
on this one for sure what are you doing
you buying the nice one or the knockoff
well it depends are you stuffing that
Bagel in a designer purse or she is are
you going like short of an Outfitter
Joanna will always ask me she'll say is
this bag a classic like she doesn't want
to buy something trendy she'll invest in
a class that's right and she's the right
person to ask because I'm like I need to
make sure that it's classic I don't live
for a trend to stand the test of time
yeah well I um carry a JanSport backpack
that would be perfect for your bag
my bagels are perfect for your JanSport
backpack
it's a match made in in durable Heaven
very affordable but I'll go and Splurge
somewhere else you know everybody has
the thing yeah absolutely you guys I
cannot thank you enough I love you both
so much for every reason Under the Sun
and
um thank you for doing this podcast with
us
it's mutual I mean everything for life
is basically my plea to you I we have so
many things to do in this world together
we do it we have so many more things to
talk about this is only like five topics
well look out for more stuff from this
throttle right here
um or just me knocking on the door of
the world's great couple CLIA and Joanna
follow the Jews News podcast wherever
you get your podcast and if you like
this well you know you can tell people
or you can see you know a tree and say
hey tree listen I don't know if you're
into podcasts but you should really
check this one out you could see you
know an alien from another planet you
could be like listen you got to check
this podcast out you could see a
neighbor's cat and say absolutely listen
you know what you should listen you
should check this podcast out um you
might even see a best friend and say you
know what I was thinking we should
listen to this together or separately
and then talk about it afterwards that's
right but wherever you are we make this
podcast for you and so just take it with
you and if you're out there in the world
and you're thinking about a friend well
just absolutely send them a message or
pick up the phone right now and tell
them that you love them
thanks everybody thank you
[Applause]
[Music]